yikes the electricity bill but just what
makes up the price of electricity in
Europe anyway let's follow the path
taken by electricity it starts in a
power plant either thermal nuclear or
renewable for example wind turbines this
is the production part then the
electricity travels long distances on a
network of high-voltage lines this is
the transportation element
it's then distributed locally on a
low-voltage Network this is the
distribution component when it reaches
your meter this is a supply part in the
European Union where the market has been
opened up any electricity producer or
supplier can access transport and
distribution networks to supply its
customers which encourages competition
three cost factors combined to make up
the final price of your kilowatts the
first is production which accounts for
40 to 50 percent either your supplier
produces the electricity or buys it from
a producer or on an exchange its price
varies depending on market conditions
such as the balance between supply and
demand and the cost of fuels then your
supplier sells the electricity at a
price that includes its costs its profit
and the services provided the second
factor is delivery to your meter which
accounts for 30 to 40 percent energy
regulators in each member state set
prices for this cost element third and
last are charges and taxes which make up
ten to thirty percent of the price since
the market has been opened up you can
influence the price of electricity and
the amount of your bill by bringing
competition between suppliers into play
so don't hesitate to compare offers what
about the most economically vulnerable
consumers they are protected by lower
rates when all said and done let's bear
in mind that the least expensive and
least polluting electricity is
electricity that's not consumed